do you know what happens when you say ok
google
tiny ml or tiny machine learning is one
of the fastest growing fields of machine
learning
it sits right at the intersection of
embedded systems
algorithms and computing hardware
tinymouth is
all about on-device machine learning
right at the end point
where the data resides and it is
fundamentally different
than running machine learning in big
data centers or in the cloud
you already know and take for granted
some existing applications a tiny amount
for instance when you say hey siri okay
google
or hey alexa you're seeing tiny amount
in action
but those applications are just the tip
of the iceberg
tiny ml has many different use cases
ranging from smart home appliances to
medical devices and it has
applications even in wildlife
conservation this exciting new
professional certificate program is a
harvard collaboration with innovative
members google's tensorflow team
this certificate combines computer
science with engineering
and it features real world application
case studies that examine tiny ml
deployments
this program takes you through the
foundations of tinyml
to deploying machine learning on your
very own device
in the foundations of tiny ml course
you'll learn the basics of embedded
computing and discover the language
behind tiny machine learning
in course 2 which focuses on the
applications of tinyml
you'll get the opportunity to see tiny
amount in practice and learn the code
behind some of the most common
applications today
finally in deploying tinyml you'll write
the machine learning code using google's
latest tensorflow lite for
microcontrollers and program your very
own smart device
we're just beginning to explore the full
capabilities of tiny amount
imagine what we could do if there were
smart ideally biodegradable machine
learning sensors
everywhere be at the forefront of this
emerging technology
and start learning tiny ml today